Hello, my name is Zisl Slepovitch
and I'm musician-in-residence at Yale
University's Fortunoff Video Archive
for Holocaust Testimonies.
This video series is designed as a companion
to our album Where Is Our Homeland,
which is the first volume in the Archive's
ongoing effort to present songs
and poems performed by survivors in
testimonies given to the Fortunoff Archive
over the last 40 years.
You can learn more about the project on the
Archive's website, songsfromtestimonies.org.
Where Is Our Homeland?
Songs From Testimonies Volume One
was recorded in 2019
by the Zisl Slepovitch Ensemble, featuring
renowned singer Sasha Lurje,
Craig Judelman on the violin, Joshua
Camp on the accordion, keyboards and
guitar, Dmitry Ishenko on the
bass, and myself on woodwinds.
The songs in this collection differ vastly
in terms of style, social and historical
background language and many other
aspects, but collectively they
create a multidimensional picture of
Jewish life before and during World
War II.
Fortunoff Video Archive testimonies hold
a wide variety of songs and
poetry.
The prewar pieces alone
form quite a large group.
They include traditional songs
of many genres, military
songs, badkhones, the
wedding jesters who plays and
recitatives, Zionist songs,
Bundist songs, communist songs,
really a wide variety of
music and poetry.
Jack M., a native of the Polish
town of Szydlowiec,
is remembering the songs that
he heard and remembered from the prewar
period.
They're not only important because
they constitute
a large part
of the ethnographic research
of Polish Jewry, of Polish culture, of
Jewish culture.
But they also portray
how the people were really
formed and shaped
before the war.
And they help us
understand who
those people really were as normal human
beings, not as just inmates,
as prisoners at concentration
camps and slave labor camps,
but human beings,
Polish citizens, Jews.
In his testimony, Jack is remembering
these songs that he
heard as he was serving in the
Polish Army.
And those are quite interesting ones.
The two songs that he remembered
were coming mostly from his commander
in his regiment.
And one is quite openly antisemitic
and the other one is rather frivolous.
Jack remembered them, he did not
consider them
really negative,
but that probably tells us
about the degree of tolerance
that the targeted
group of population, groups, societal
group develops as a survival
tool.
Eh, we were laughing
at, on us, the Christians.
Antisemitic all around me,
the, they made up a song,
the took, they took a
Jew, took them to the Army
in,
in.
Instead, to give him rolls
with butter, he give
him a cabbage soup.
He made up a song like that.
You remember the song?
Yes, in Polish,
yeah.
A poor little Yid
got drafted.
They took out a poor,
a poor guy.
He got no bread with butter,
just cabbage soup.
They didn't give you dough.
And then he said, he said.
They gave him a gun,
loaded with onions,
And told him to shoot his wife.
He gave him a rifle.
He said to load it with a gun-- the guns
should be loaded with ammunition.
They put in the onion.
An onion in.
He ask him, he should, he should shoot to
his own wife.
That was the total.
Were there songs that you knew in the army
or sang in the army?
Far away from us, yah.
But--
Lider.
Lider vos du hast gezungen in militar.
Plenty, plenty lider, eh.
Efshar lomir horen a lid.
I don't know.
A lot of to think.
Yeah, eh, that song
goes like that.
About a girl
and about a soldier.
Eh... you understand Polish?
On a stone sat
a gray pigeon,
I¡¯d give you a kiss,
but don¡¯t tell anyone.
If you were to tell,
I wouldn¡¯t feel ashamed
That you kissed me.
I wouldn¡¯t mind that.
In the hopes that the, everybody
was singing the melody after him.
There¡¯s a wagon going,
all painted,
I will give you a kiss,
when Mother falls asleep.
Da, da, da, da,
Yeah. Now, now it says
Mother has fallen asleep,
the fireplace is dark.
The girl gives a kiss,
and the bed shakes.
Da, da, da, yeah.
This is, this is a
merry song, yeah yeah yeah
yeah yeah.
Un ir hat gezungen in eynem mit dem
polnishe soldaten.
Mit alla zusammen, mit alle zusammen.
A poor little Yid
got drafted.
He got no bread with butter,
just cabbage soup.
They gave him a gun,
loaded with onions,
And told him to shoot his wife.
On a stone sat
a gray pigeon,
I¡¯d give you a kiss,
but don¡¯t tell anyone.
If you were to tell,
I wouldn¡¯t feel ashamed
That you kissed me.
I wouldn¡¯t mind that.
There¡¯s a wagon going,
all painted,
I will give you a kiss,
when Mother falls asleep.
Mother has fallen asleep,
the fireplace is dark.
The girl gives a kiss,
and the bed shakes.
I'm talking today about
two songs which were recorded by an
amateur folk singer, Jack Milstein,
a Polish Jew.
He served in the Polish Army.
He was born in 1913.
So he served in the Polish Army
in the late 20s
and early 30s.
This was a difficult
time, I think, for Jews
in the Polish army, the NCOs,
the officers, indeed, the men were not
that sympathetic towards Jewish
recruits, particularly ones who
were not that acculturated.
Most times speaks, sings his two
songs in Polish.
I mean, he has a slight accent in Polish,
but his Polish is clearly good and he has
no problems either recording
in Polish or indeed presumably speaking in
Polish.
The first song is
a song about, so-called humorous
song, mocking Jewish recruits.
Instead of loading his gun
with bullets, the Jewish recruit
loads his gun with onions.
Of course onions and
Jews, like garlic and Jews, is one of those
East European tropes.
And not only does he load his gun with
onions, but he shoots at his
wife and his wife is called not
kobieta, but kobita, the women.
It's a rather
lower class Polish expression.
The other song he sings is a
love song and it's a rather
attractive song.
I mean, I don't see it as being humorous or
in any sense anti-Jewish.
And what it reflects, in my view, is
the degree to which Polish popular culture
had penetrated into the Jewish
world in the 1920s and the 1930s,
although particularly after 1935,
antisemitism increased in Poland.
And indeed in the early years of the
Pilsudski regime, after Pilsudski
took power in May
1926, the government
attempted to reach an understanding with
the various national minorities and indeed
with the Jews. And until the death of
General Pilsudski in May 1935,
Jews felt relatively comfortable.
But throughout this
period, in the period when the
Jewish situation was relatively good
after 1926 and as it deteriorated
first under the impact of the Great
Depression and then after the death of
Marshal Pilsudski when a section of the
government camp attempted to strengthen
its position by making common
cause with the antisemitic part of
the Polish right, there
was a high degree of acculturation taking
place. So along with the
deterioration of the situation of the Jews,
they went and adopted the Polish language.
And I think this is reflected
in Milstein's songs.
He sings songs in Polish.
He has no problem singing these songs
in Polish, and he's clearly
quite comfortable singing them in Polish.
So they reflect, on the one hand, the
ambivalent position of the Jews, relatively
stable in the late 1920s and early
1930s when Milstein is serving
in the Polish army, deteriorating
after 1935.
But also it reflects the growing
acculturation of Jews.
And one element in this, which
perhaps is linked with these songs
is the fact that Polish popular culture,
Polish popular music, Polish songs
were an area where
Jews were extremely
active.
Jews were among the people who produced
jazz, Wlast and
the other major Jewish singers.
These were people who were
accepted on the larger Polish scene.
And as in the United States,
the Polish equivalent of Tin Pan Alley
had a heavily Jewish
component.